i am oh for four i'm guessing what these
woke commercials are actually selling
as their product but hope springs
eternal in the human breast
so i'm going to try again this one comes
from seth
let's roll the tape
around me hey the guy's a boss
the woman is bossy oh yeah
poor women you're raising me one of
these one of these feminism commercials
okay so he's persuasive
she's pushy yeah that's it women have it
so hard in this country
that's why they live longer and make up
most college students right
because of how hard they have it you
know she's selfish
[Music]
neat and vain oh yeah yeah we never give
women credit for their physical beauty
no never not in this
[Music]
it's country show-off yeah wow gosh it's
hard out there for uh for a lady today
[Music]
i have no idea don't let labels hold you
back
i i have no idea what this is be strong
and shine
pantene prophy
not even a hint i was thinking there's a
chance it could be like a clothing
commercial because it was so much of it
was about the the clothing and the
fashion but no it wasn't even that
shampoo shampoo wants you to know
that we live in a patriarchy and women
can't get anything and women are always
put down and criticized
and men are always exalted is so
wonderful now of course in reality that
isn't the case
in reality is there any is there
anything worse today
in political dialogue than being a man
you know or a straight white man right
that's like considered the worst
possible thing ever
and women are considered just
universally wonderful and that's why we
need to
have everything be very feminist and and
anti-patriarchal
but i guess in the silly bizarro world
of pantene pro-v
it's the opposite so nope didn't get it
and probably won't be buying any more
pantene pro v next commercial next
commercial
hopefully will allow me to redeem myself
this this commercial was suggested by
the youtube user of the point of
everything podcast
but before we jump into it i just have
to point out this video is sponsored by
hallow hallow is an audio guided
catholic meditation and prayer app
sort of like headspace or calm but it's
for prayer you know it's not just
leaving it at the level of meditation
but
elevating a little higher it's the
number one catholic app in the united
states it's free to download there is
also
permanently free content there so you
don't need to pay for anything there's
always free content
but there's also wonderful extra stuff
on there as well for a 14-day free trial
you can go to hallow.com michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l
hallow.com michael m-i-c-h-a-e-l
especially these days
where everybody seems really on edge and
everyone's just distracted
by the nonsense of this world myself
included a lot of the time
this is a wonderful way to center your
prayer life hallow.com
michael or click on the link in the bio
now back to the stupid distracting
nonsense of this world the material
goods that are being sold in woke
commercials
roll the tape
everybody wakes up happy it's true
sometimes you feel sad scared crappy
yeah oh this is going to be a wrap i can
sense that
that you let me feel my way
a woman's called a spanking this is a
pantene can't wait to leave this
closed-minded town
rural america
[Music]
this is like very generically liberal
i don't i don't know what it's not just
like only feminist or something
[Music]
it's like a movie leave my student loan
i'm never moving out of my parents home
just got ghosted i should have known
pretty sure i'm gonna say something like
a moving company because it's all about
moving and leaving
i'm too young to raise my baby girl take
your opinions
and suck it world
[Music]
it's actually kind of nice that she
raised the kid and didn't do abortion or
something like that
it's pretty good they think it's woke
but it's not it's actually pretty
conservative
throwing his phone away i'm still going
to stick with like a moving something
[Music]
it's a long commercial no one is happy
all the time
and that's okay stop it
stop
is that a a burger king it's just burger
king
i guess a happy meal like a i guess
there's a tie in there
oh my gosh and then at the end burger
king supports the work of
mentalhealthamerica.net
that i you know i gotta tell you there's
something very distasteful about that i
like the pun
of it's a happy meal and no one's happy
all the time
but to to exploit people who are going
through like clinical depression
and we're feeling suicidal to sell a
cheap hamburger that is
that's exploitative that's too far it's
funny though that's the funniest one of
these i've seen probably
probably accidentally funny don't you do
you remember the old burger king
commercial
the bigger the burger the better the
burger burger is bigger at burger king
that's all it was now it's just like
yeah i want to kill myself and i hate my
girlfriend and my mom
beats me and i don't it's that's too
much go back to bigger the burger that's
better all right can i is there any way
i was so off okay we're gonna get a
bonus video in
uh this one was requested by cindy
gonzalez so now i'm what i i was over
four going in
now i'm over six i thought i was close
on the moving one i
obviously was not so this will be
seven lucky number seven the third the
bonus woke commercial that the producers
queued up because they
knew i wasn't going to get these let's
try
one more for the road
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's a sort of larger woman saying i
should lose weight
it should work out if you take away the
quotes
then these are probably true statements
[Music]
stop shooting yourself
halo 2 is that ice cream it's an ice
cream company
it's a okay well you know actually that
i
i mean it was actually a little bit
short so i couldn't quite guess it i
could tell from the commercial that
the the premise of the commercial is
that people who are very very overweight
are always told that they should lose
weight and and be
in a healthier but really they shouldn't
be
so i could assume it was going to be
some kind of
body positive what are they called no
fat shaming kind of thing
but that's very on the nose that is very
on the nose to say
yes i'm if i'm out of shape or i'm
you know i'm in ill health i shouldn't
get into better health
i should eat a lot of ice cream that is
so i actually give them points for just
bluntness and directness because that's
what our culture says right now right is
that any time
you restrain restrain yourself in any
way any time
you put some constraints on your own
life and you
you say no to certain appetites or
desires that's bad
that's not letting you live your best
life people who are kind of healthy and
moderate and rest and and work out and
eat and
do their work and have some leisure
those people are suckers
they're total people who don't just
indulge every appetite they've ever had
they're they're losers right they're
they're not uh living their best life
really it's just the people who engorge
all of their appetites be they
uh for food or for drink or for sex or
for
idleness or whatever those are the guys
who are living their best life go eat
some ice cream i perhaps will have some
ice cream to console myself
after i got much closer on that one but
alas scott got all of them wrong
i suppose we'll try again next time
please send in your suggestions for
these commercials
try to make them a little easier next
time because
because they're you're getting better
you're getting better with the ice cream
let's all have a nice scoop of ice cream
try again next time
[Music]
you